we have breaking news from Russia where
a deadly explosion rocked to the subway
in Saint Petersburg a local government
spokesman says at least 10 people were
killed and 50 others injured
Jonathan Vigliotti is following this
breaking story from London Jonathan good
morning good morning Russian officials
say the explosion happened while the
train was travelling between two
stations video from the immediate
aftermath showed the destruction the
explosion so powerful it blew off metal
doors smoke clogged several stations on
the line as Metro riders were seen
trying to enter the damaged train car to
rescue people at this stage officials
say 10 people were killed and dozens
injured state-run television is
reporting children were among the
victims
they said the blasts involved what they
described as a device filled with
shrapnel President Putin was in st.
Petersburg at that time and said
terrorism is one of the working theories
but at this point police say the exact
cause remains unclear charlie
jonathan thanks